- Checking connection, you are now live.
Hello!
We are telling your followers
that you started a live video.
I just tried it.
You're so kind.
(Kelly laughs)
Hello! I'm in between shows.
Oh, what's up Tammy?
I am in between shows right now
and I thought we'd do an Instagram Live
for y'all.
I didn't think that
somebody else thought it would be cool
and I'm not cool
and I have to think of
something like that,
let's just be real,
but I was like, "Yeah, let's do it."
So anyway, happy new year everybody,
this is our first Instagram Live of 2022
and happy new year y'all,
I hope you all are having
a great year so far.
I know some things haven't changed,
global pandemic, but we're working on it
I think as human race, we wanna get there.
Anyway, there's a surge
happening now in LA
and specifically I know,
so we have no audience right now,
it's all virtual for a minute.
Again, but we do have
left guests, which is fine
and we're keeping it safe,
so we wanted to keep all our people safe,
so that's why we did that,
but anyway, just wanna say happy new year
and I hear that we are almost,
I heard a million followers,
we're almost a million
followers, so come on,
we all know 6,000 people.(laughs)
Just call them.(laughs)
- [Tricia] A lot of you.
- If one of you calls 6,000 people,
we can do this.(laughs)
We're a little tired,
so this should go well
and we have no one here,
it's just me and Tricia
who are so not good at stuff like that,
such a party.
Anyway, so I think
I'm gonna be answering questions, right?
- Yes.
- I'm answering questions,
you've so many questions
and I'm going to answer them.
- [Tricia] Gracie wants to know,
what is a typical day schedule like
when you're filming "The
Kelly Clarkson Show"
from makeup to sleep?
- Oh, well I'll tell
you about my day today.
I let my kids have a sleepover last night
because I was so tired.
Listen, I'm one of those tools
that's like, "Man, you're no man."
and I'll start to work it out
and I also started working again
like after having,
the longest period I've had off,
I feel like in 20 years,
which was like 20 days maybe.
So most of that was with kids,
so not super often
but it was not working
and so we got back to work
and all of us were like,
"Oh my gosh, is everyone really tired?"
And then pluses are working out.
So I was really tired
and I was literally like,
I couldn't even go up
the stairs to my kids,
but I was like, "You
know, it's going to be fun
if we have a sleep over."
And they love sleepovers
and I don't allow it unless it's weekends,
but mama was tired, I couldn't do it.
I couldn't do the whole
routine, I couldn't.
So I let them sleep with me
and they were so excited.
So I woke up this morning
to my five and seven year old
giggling and laughing.
It was wonderful.
And we all were cuddling and hugging.
And then I said, "Okay,
we have to get up."
Cause we were already 20 minutes late.
And I know my nanny was like,
"We got to start at some point."
So she has three kids sometimes.
So anyways,
so we got the kids up
and she helped me with
the kids this morning
and while I was getting ready
and then I had to get to work
a little bit earlier
because we actually have,
today is an odd day.
My music director,
I feel like he has never taken a day off
in his whole life.
He had just some family stuff come up.
So we had to go and help his family.
And so we have touch,
I filling in as our musical director.
So were here just a tiny bit early
to go through the show
and everyone's kind of getting back.
And then we read scripts.
I read scripts with
Alex executive producer.
Well, I read them the night before,
but I mean, we just kind
of go through the show
and how it's going to go.
And if there are any questions,
usually this is the time
when I don't how to
pronounce someone's name.
And then usually we do
rehearsals for songs,
but we haven't been doing that.
I've just been doing it
right before I sing them.
So then we go down and
we do the show I sing
and then we do the show
and then we have a break.
And sometimes I'm doing stuff like this
in my break right after lunch.
And then we do a whole other show.
We should do two shows a day.
We always not usually, we always what?
Wrong word.
We always do two shows a day.
And then we finish up,
we do the same kind of thing again
with a different show, different people.
And that's the cool thing about it.
It's kinda like musical theater
in the sense of every show is different.
I mean, it's not the
same script obviously,
but I just mean every same people
and same kind of dynamics,
but it's like different
live setting every time.
So it's kind of fun in that sense.
And you know, depending on the day,
karaokes go well, or they don't,
it's literally, people don't get it.
I'm literally learning the song
right before I sing it.
So if they're not like staples,
like always on my mind,
Willie Nelson, something like that.
But so yeah,
that happens pretty quickly.
And then I go home
and then I hang with my kids.
And last night we did puzzles.
My son is into puzzles
and my daughter is into right now,
saying that everything we do is not cool.
And we were trying to
get Mario brothers work.
I couldn't because Tricia's the one
that knows how to build stuff
and I couldn't get it,
technology is not my friend.
So anyway, and that's it.
And then, yeah,
we'll end up probably snuffing again,
cause I'm so tired.
Working out is exhausting
if you don't do it normally.
And then all of a sudden you're like,
"It's January, I'm gonna be that tool
that works out for a month?"
Yeah.
It's like an 18 minute workout too.
It's an 18-minute workout Tricia.
You know what?
You do the 18 minutes.
Tricia's gonna do 18 minutes.
- [Tricia] I have time
for about 15 minutes.
- Okay. It's circuits
and it's hard if you got to...
Becky, I don't know
how I can talk on here.
I don't know what
you're allowed to say on here, so.
- [Tricia] Okay, question number two.
- Okay.
- [Tricia] Joan Suzanne,
what song do you wish
you had written from another artist?
- Plenty.
Oh my God! There's so many songs I love.
So I mean,
my go-to is probably
"Why" by any Any Links.
I just fell in love
with that song as a kid,
I love it and I love how it's written.
It's not formulaic
like how most songs are written.
That's probably,
I mean, there's a lot
like any YouTube song,
you know what I'm saying?
There's like a lot of songs
that you wish you'd written.
Yeah, I should've been more prepared
for that question.
- [Tricia] This is a good one.
Aaron wants to know.
Would you ever rerecord
some of your older hits
with your current sound and frame of mind?
- Yes.
And you know why?
It's not really cause a friend of mine
or anything,
it's because I feel like I was tweeting
and I feel like it was Tailor Swift
cause she wouldn't want
to redo or whatever.
And I was like,
"You should just recut them all."
And I think what's
interesting about doing that
later in life is,
one, I personally feel like
my voice is stronger than
it was when I was 19.
It should be, I mean, I hope so.
Like after working hard for 20 years
and it should've gotten a little better,
so I feel like my range is bigger
and it's just a different voice.
So I think it would be
interesting to rerecord
some of those songs that I love
or even some of the hits
that I actually can't listen to
because sometimes also,
look, I'm just trying to sometimes,
like sometimes the producer
keeps you there so long
and 99% of the time
get along with all producers and humanity,
but there's a 1% where I'm just like,
"Oh, you're not going to
let me leave this studio
until I sing it exactly
how you're wanting to.
like with a ye ho, instead of you."
Or things like that,
that I can't listen to my own music
because it's just weird.
So I would like to,
I think that would be fun to do,
like at this stage of my life,
with my voice now,
I think that would be really cool.
- [Tricia] Yeah. Heather wants to know,
what has been one of your favorite songs
to cover so far in karaoke?
- Oh, you know what?
I actually, this is a reason I have a ton.
I love covering obviously.
It's why we incorporated on the show.
So I love covering music,
but I will say,
she used to be mine.
The one we just did
from Sarah Barelas, a
waitress, the musical.
I had like heard the song before
and I thought,
"Oh, that was pretty."
But I maybe had only heard it once before.
I never actually got to see the waitress.
I'm never in New York.
And when I am,
it's there for a split second,
like working the whole time.
So I never had the chance to see it.
And Jessie, my backyard singer,
she was like, "Oh my God, I'll cry."
She was like, "It's amazing."
And I was like, "Oh man,
I heard the song once."
And I remember thinking
how beautiful it was,
but I didn't really know it.
And I literally learned
it seconds right before
because of how the timing of the day went.
I had no rehearsal time, no learning time.
And so I literally like inductor, sorry,
this phone is going dead.
But anyway, she was conducting me
at certain parts to come
because I was like, "Oh my God."
I was like, "I don't wanna run this
because it's such a beautiful song."
And I wanted to do it justice.
And I feel like
when I really, really love a song,
that's when I get like more OCD about it.
But what's funny is
I was so enthralled
because I got to watch the dancers
before I did it.
And I knew what they were doing
and the dancers, oh my God,
they were so beautiful.
There's just something so magical
about hearing a live performance,
seeing the live performance happen
while you're sonically hearing it as well.
That was one of my favorite things
to be a part of, for sure,
more so because the dancers, yeah.
And the song was just beautiful.
God, what lyrics?
Well, I was like, "Jeez!"
- [Tricia] It's time to
play Fill in the blank.
- Oh, it's time to play Fill in the blank.
Cause I'm long-winded,
there were so many questions
that I didn't get to.
Sorry, so sorry.
(all laughing)
Okay, wait, fill in the blank.
The place I want to visit most in 2022 is,
my home.
Because I think...
And the beach,
because my family, my kids,
I've decided this year,
there's just gonna be a
couple of changes for me
that I can't say here,
but there's a couple things happening
and I've been able to make more time,
just for me and my kiddos
and still be able to work,
and just where we can get away on weekends
and like really do some
fun stuff with my kids,
cause they only want to hang out with you
for so long.
And so I that's now,
so I got to take advantage of that.
So I'm really excited.
It's not really where, it's with,
and I'm excited to have
more time with them.
I mean, I have a ton
of time in the morning,
but I'm running, I'm selfish.
I love them, they're fun.
I always feel bad,
like that friend that they're,
everybody's like, "Let's hang out."
And I'm like, "I'm like my kids,
I'm like hanging out with them."
I like Disney, I like Legos,
all those things.
I will finally get Blank
as a guest on my show.
Hi Meryl, hi.
I love Meryl Streep,
Meryl Streep, I said Meryl Street
I'm still not coming now.
I'm so tired.
No, I would obviously
love to have Meryl Streep.
Anybody would have loved
to have her on the show,
but I don't know.
I'm a huge fan of a lot of people.
And I honestly feel super blessed
that all the people
I've been able to hang out with,
like Sandra Bullock,
was so fun.
That was really cool.
And I dunno,
I feel like I've had a lot of great people
already on the show.
Everything now is like cherry on top.
I feel like,
but I like a lot of people.
I'd be excited about a lot of people,
but I think everybody expects me
to say Meryl Streep
because I love her,
with a P, Streep, okay.
An artist I'd love to
cover and a karaoke is,
oh, you know what I want to do?
I just talked about this
yesterday with Jesse,
I'm a procrastinator.
I was like, "You know what you do?
I want to do a Spanish song,
like all in Spanish.
I think that'd be really cool.
And in my workout routine
was listening to this certain,
I don't know, somebody
workout mix on Spotify.
Thank you.
But Marc Anthony came up
and I love working Marc Anthony
and I love this song.
I got to find out what song it is.
But anyway, it's one I want to cover.
I like, I can't remember her name.
Is it Rosalia or Rosalie?
I like her too.
I can't remember, I'm forgetting every,
I'm messing up everyone's name today,
but she's really good too.
But I think it'd be cool
to do something in Spanish.
Anyway, so that'd be cool.
A new skill or talent
I'd like to learn is,
oh God, I mean, I don't know,
I guess it's-
- Spanish?
- to learn Spanish. (laughs)
Duo lingo, I was so disappointed in me.
So no, I think it's really to cook.
I've been cooking more
cause we go to the beach.
I like to just throw my kids.
Honestly, I've been eating
my food, which is...
They don't normally eat anyone's food.
So I think cook more is maybe the thing
just because we have vegetables
that we grow at our house.
So one of my favorite things to do
is my girl and I, we love bell peppers,
we're just like Bragg's liquid amino
and like Himalayan salt
and like goat cheese.
Anyway, it's really good.
So, I like using this
stuff from our garden
when we're cooking.
That's cool.
The one thing...
I already said that kind of,
I've been putting off
Blan for a long time,
but this year I'm going to do it.
Oh God, it's a whole list.
Or I'm working out.
I'm gonna try and stick to it.
Here's the thing you guys,
I feel like it's just a different time
in my life.
I'm turning 40 this
year and I'm just like,
"Look, as long as the
doctors isn't helping,
I'm good."
And I'm fine, so, but I didn't,
I didn't want to do that though,
because I do like feeling strong.
That's the difference,
I do, I like feeling strong.
Even when you're rolling out of bed
in the morning,
sometimes when I wake up I'm like,
"Oh my God, everything hurts."
Well, that's now because I'm working out.
But I want to get to that point
to where I just feel like really strong.
I like that feeling, stronger.
Didn't even plan it.
Okay.
The food I went to alert to cook most is?
Oh, I just wanna cook more of most stuff
from my garden.
That's what I wanna cook with.
I'm going to face my
fear of Blank this year.
I don't have a fear,
I don't have any fears,
I don't think, I mean, I'm sure.
I mean, I don't want anything
to happen to my family,
that's a fear,
but I don't have like
one I'm going to face.
I don't think I have anything like that.
I hope the book Blank
is turned into a movie.
Okay, you see my necklace?
Okay, so it's a cheetah
and it's from Untamed, Glennon Doyle.
And I know it's usually
like a fiction book
or some book that's a true story,
that gets turned into a movie,
but wouldn't it be cool
if you don't know Glennon, Doyle story?
It would be a really sad movie.
Like, I mean, there's so much story there
and so much to relate to
and so much perseverance,
so much overcoming.
She's got a really great story
and she's very inspiring.
And I also think it would be fun
to make it a dark comedy
with like Leslie Mann,
is that I love her.
I think she's funny.
Anyway, I think she
should be Glennon Doyle.
And I think there should
be a movie, Untamed,
and no one would steal this idea
if you did one word with her.
Okay.
I am most excited to reveal this year
that I am?
Oh, well.
(all laughing)
It's the most boring live ever
on Instagram.
I can't, there is, are rather,
there are a few things happening this year
that are different for me.
I'll give you a hint.
One is something people
have been asking for
for quite some time.
We'll hint to that.
And then the other is,
well also people have been asking
for a few years now,
there's a clue, but no,
that's no secret.
I do, I'm hoping to get
a record out this year.
Obviously we have the...
There's just been a lot
going on in my life.
Obviously I don't look,
I'm not on the news or whatever,
but I hear from people
so I know what everybody else knows,
but there's just a lot going on.
I just kinda wanted my life
to kind of be a little more steady,
like rock steady before jumping
into a giant project.
So I've got a ton of music
that I've been writing
over the past few years actually.
And so hopefully get that's one thing
I can pretty much say
we're going to get that out.
But then there's one before that
that's kind of what I think
people may be excited about.
And if you're not whatever,
and then there's something
else that's different
that I can't discuss,
but it's gonna happen and it's pretty big.
So, yeah.
Did I miss them?
I feel like I might've missed them.
Oh, what did I say?
Oh, I didn't.
I just didn't know where it was
because there was altogether.
What did I not do?
- [Tricia] It would be really cool
to able to perform at?
- It would be really cool
to be able to perform at?
Okay.
So, I recently got into sports ball.
(Tricia clapping)
Here's the thing,
I think I just leaned in
because I am surrounded by people
that love sports ball,
like every sport possible.
And over Christmas,
my sister is one of those people
and her husband, my brother-in-law, Shawn,
they love football.
And I grew up around football in Texan.
Go cowboy
But anyways,
so I literally maybe having some to drink
and I was living with my family
and we were watching,
I got really in to football.
I got very mad.
I got very, I mean, I'm talking real
and I got real mad
cause there was this one Cardinals game,
I'm not even a Cardinals fan,
but I mean, go you.
but I just mean, I'm a Cowboys fan,
but I was so mad
cause it was like,
right when the game,
this guy's feet,
it would have been a touchdown.
His team was in the back,
they didn't even question,
they were like, "Oh!"
And I kept asking my brother-in-law like,
"What's that?"
Why would they not do this?"
Anyway, and it would have been
a really great catch for this dude,
like in his,
anyway, it was a great catch.
You, I don't remember your name.
I'm not there yet.
I'm not quite obsessed
to that space yet with sports ball,
but I did get really into sports ball.
And so I forgot how this ties in
with the question.
So I haven't able to perform
at sports ball events
for like the past 4 years,
I've learned a ton about,
but now I feel like
I'm like super into it.
It's like even more fun.
So yeah, I think my friends
would like that too.
They like sports
and I've had to say no a lot
because I'm so busy.
So maybe seeing it's more sports things
cause I just got real
into it and now I'm like,
"We did go to a Lakers game as well."
And that was a lot of fun.
Maybe not with my children next time
because they're young
and one of them enjoyed it,
but one of them was like, "Hmm."
But anyway, that's yeah.
I think maybe that any
kind of sporting thing,
that'd be fun.
I don't, I don't know.
I don't remember.
- [Tricia] Any habit you
wanna give up this year?
- A bad habit I'm going
to give it this year?
I mean, I have them.
I don't, I'm sure.
Right now, I don't know.
What's about, you know, bad habits.
What are my bad habits?
I've said them probably multiple times.
- [Tricia] I don't know that.
I don't think there is.
- Or a challenge
or something to work on.
I have plenty of that time.
- [Tricia] Time management.
- Time management is not my forte.
I'm not like a late person.
I mean, usually I'm the
person that you work with
and they're like,
"Oh, she's, you can
count the dues on time."
It's more of like in my life,
I'm not good at like more me.
Oh, you know what
I need to work on this year?
So someone told me
I needed to start treating myself
how I treat others.
I was like, how was
like, when they told me,
I was like, "Oh!"
It was a really good advice though.
And you don't think about it,
but sometimes we're a
lot hard on ourselves
and we aren't others.
And so I was like,
"I'm going to start doing that."
So that's one thing,
and time management,
and Tricia's right.
Well, that's just one
running that schedule.
And she's like, so what?
We're less busy now.
People always give me
crap for being so busy.
We are we're so we don't, we have a life.
We go to the beach, we go to eat,
we go to sporting events.
I just went to so far
stadium and saw the Rams
versus the 49-ers, which is Trisha's team.
She was happy there in the playoffs.
I know what those are.
We do. We play each other
next Sunday, Sunday,
and we're going to be together.
We drink the wine
and I am going to be so excited
because Dak is just going to hand a tool.
Yeah, that's right.
I know all your names.
I'm so excited, I'm so excited.
Yeah.
Wrap it up. You're boring.
So the reason why we're rubbing it up
is cause I have to go shoot another show.
So, but this has been well,
I don't know if it's been fun.
I'm sorry I'm wasted your time.
I hope I answered your questions.
Well, I don't,
I should have maybe looked at those
more thoroughly
before doing this,
but I glanced and I thought they were fine
and I hope I answered them,
and we do have some fun stuff
coming this year.
So I'm excited about that.
And I'm not excited that I can tell you
follow the kind of Carson show,
it should follow the
Kelly Clarkson Instagram.
Oh, to the followers.
Oh.
So we have like a lot of followers,
call your 6,000 people right now.
And if you have 6,000 friends go you.
Oh. And then he had all these things here,
like for me to just be so excited,
happy new year,
that was probably
unnecessarily loud in your ear.
I'm so sorry.
But I'm afraid.
I don't even know how to do this.
What way do you think
it's going to pop off or
it's all there.
It's all over there?
I didn't know what it was going to do.
Oh wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, there were two sides.
There always are.
Okay. I'm here.
So sorry. This is the
weirdest Instagram Live
you probably ever...
Anyway, I love you guys.
Thank you so much for
supporting the show really.
And anyway, I hope that I did this right.
I don't really do these things, so,
and no one's here helping us, so whatever.
I don't know how to get out of here.
Oh and exit.
Okay.
Bye.